[Musique]
c'est petites fleurs violettes jaunes et
blanches ressemblent à de petits
papillons
ses feuilles à la nervure franches sont
couvertes d'un petit duvet qui les
rendent douce l'a brisé dit mastrotto au
panama ou santa maría au venezuela
est une plante qui mesure 1 à 2 mètres
de haut et qui pousse dans toute la
caraïbe ainsi qu'en amérique tropicale
et subtropicale
très utilisé par nos grands mères la
décoction de feuilles de briser à la
réputation de soigner la grippe le rhume
et la fatigue
les recherches menées le permis d'y
détecter des monos terpènes des
molécules aux propriétés
décongestionnantes
ainsi que des alcaloïdes qui composent
le principe actif de nombreux
médicaments
dans le cadre de son projet pac man
le parc est allé encore plus loin ce qui
rassure les sens sur la reprise et c'est
qu'on a remarqué à travers les travaux
menés une activité
antibactériennes et antifongiques de
l'huile essentielle de feuilles de
briser en parallèle on a aussi découvert
une forte activité antioxydante toujours
sur des extraits de feuilles de brive et
est également une activité
anti-inflammatoire
alors à partir de ces résultats un max
de développement qui pourraient être
envisagées sur les feuilles de briser ce
serait justement de rentrer dans la
composition d'un complément alimentaire
qui auraient des propriétés digestives
et antioxydantes par exemple
[Musique]
ils se cachent encore bien des
applications derrière la brise est un
nom qui vient sans doute d'ailleurs de
l'odeur si tronic dégage la feuille
canton la brise de quoi imaginer une
éventuelle valorisation en parfumerie
par ailleurs une fois transformée en
huile essentielle elle a des effets sur
plusieurs germes ont ainsi empêché la
croissance c'est le cas par exemple de
la bactérie e-coli qui peut se
développer dans le tube digestif ou du
staphylocoque doré bactéries qui
entraîne les affections cutanées
mais attention
quel que soit le mal que vous voulez
crie t il faut toujours être prudent si
les blancs peuvent soigner mieux vaut
demander conseil à votre médecin